Italy is preparing to shut down the
region of Lombardi to contain the spread
of coronavirus the number of people who
died from coronavirus in Italy has
jumped by 36 since yesterday the figure
now stands at 233 the number of cases
has also risen dramatically by over a
thousand to five thousand eight hundred
and eighty three a draft decree outlines
measures to stop people from entering or
leaving the area which includes the
financial capital Milan my correspondent
arenda Brady joins me now and what more
detail do we have about this this
lockdown in Italy well these are very
tough measures being put in place
tonight by the Italian government to try
and stop the further spread of the
coronavirus Italy remains Europe's worst
his country 233 fatalities over the past
few weeks and day on day those numbers
are growing so if we look at the
measures and basically the entire region
of Lombardi will be locked down until at
least the 3rd of April nobody will be
allowed out and nobody will be allowed
in and they're saying that there will be
fines for people caught entering or
leaving and it's very very serious so
the decree provides for banning all
public events they're going to close
cinemas theaters gyms discos and pubs
religious ceremonies such as funerals
and weddings will also be banned now
this is in the north of the country
there are 20 regions in Italy and the
epicenter of the outbreak really
Lombardi has been is neighboring regions
if you look you've got Emilia Romagna
and Veneto as well but there are 11
other affected areas that will also be
subject to this degree but but decree
but the region of Lombardy is
effectively in lockdown
as of tonight until the 3rd of April a
very serious move some would say
draconian but the Italian government
have to get on top of this because day
on day it has got worse for Italy and
the virus has continued to spread if you
look at the figures you know 85% of the
cases in the whole of Italy are in those
three regions Lombardi Emilia Romagna
and the Veneto and they account for a
92% of recorded deaths so it is Lombardy
their focus
and tonight once this decree is signed
off by the Prime Minister Conte that
would be it long Bertie will be shut
down of course Milan is in the heart of
LA I was gonna say financial capital
Milan you know thriving metropolis that
we shut down is going to have
far-reaching consequences
it's a massive decision but the Italian
government tonight is signing off this
draft legislation and the impact on
their businesses on flights coming in
and out if you look at tourism as well
the projected loss already to tourism
and for the months that have been
affected so far and for the months to
come in the region of 6.4 billion pounds
so it is a huge huge decision but the
Italian government are moving fast now
tonight tough new measures coming in as
a result of this decree and we're
hearing as well that health care workers
in the region of Lombardy will not be
allowed to take any leave so they're
basically going to work flat out to try
and stop the spread of the virus before
it gets anywhere